[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you should be able to hear me now
oh my God I can't even open my window
all right so as you can see we were
gonna play some Call of Duty I had every
intention on playing Call of Duty but
I didn't realize I deleted it
and that what so happens when you make a
98 gig game
if I don't play it you get deleted so I
am downloading that so hopefully we'll
play that relatively here in the next
couple hours I am waiting for King and
all then to uh to join
it's awesome King another invite
oh that's what's up dead proof I
appreciate all the uh happy birthdays I
do appreciate it
oh I don't want to spill that that would
be horrible
what is going on outside why is there so
many
there's like something crazy going on
outside right now hold up
foreign
oh
out of uh a one to ten how loud is that
noise outside
how loud is that noise outside
it's pretty loud on my end but my
windows closed so I don't know if you
guys can hear it pretty bad
let me move this up so I can keep muting
my mic it's closer
all right so it's not too bad it doesn't
look like you guys hear it like
drastically bad
okay can you hear me
hello oh can you hear me yes can you
hear me
yeah okay cool it's
every time I [ __ ] turn this [ __ ] on I
gotta remember how to use it
yeah you play that switch and that uh
steam deck too much yeah I'm not home
otherwise I would play on my Xbox
I turned this [ __ ] on it's like you have
10 updates I'm like [ __ ]
uh homies send King a message and tell
him I've sent him three invites and I
don't know why he he well he said no he
said he has a
in the chat he wrote something about um
he has like an appointment or some [ __ ]
and then he's coming out
hi what's going on yo oh no yeah he says
he's on right now I said you oh you make
sure it's not capitalized
I sent you a invite oh yes okay I said
he has to leave it too
uh
all right I I see some of you already
asking about you know
uh joining in it will happen okay just
bear with me give me a couple seconds
here what's up
who's hiding
what are you talking about he is
appearing offline
sir he's just like me don't worry about
it
[Music]
comes a bunch of right now I'm playing
some fortnite
uh
to the chat
it was how cold do I got
okay I gotta be able to get this I got
the tunes playing next I don't
okay look I'm not gonna say
that what they did is gonna like
miraculously
fix everything that's been wrong
oh my God man
I'm not gonna say what they did is like
drastically gonna fix everything but
what I will say
is
it's it's crazy
what Halo infinite is right now like
that the stuff that I've seen
two dollar from drawing TJ tell CAD uh
tell King David High I mean he could
hear you so you can easily tell them
yourself
uh so it's just crazy
the what what the Halo Community has
done with this creation tool
like it's absolutely that's why it took
so long for it to show up
you know hear all these little wacky
dudes talking all the hills dead now
huh yeah
listen
it's the game passes the vehicle
so
it's meant to be new anytime you go in
it
all right so who wants to play uh we
gotta wait for college so we need uh to
keep that spot open so keep that in mind
chat uh I can't just let all of you in
here you know I try to get kids smooth
in here one more time he's playing uh
high on life I do plan on streaming that
eventually
um
ridiculous I think people are a huge
Rick and Morty fan so I think people are
ridiculous
shout out it's pretty fun ducky ten
dollars Super Chat happy birthday my man
hope you have a good day
appreciate it appreciate that
um call getting on you but yeah so I
have some crazy I I spent about two two
and a half hours looking through
the these popular maps that that's in
the community tab as you can see there's
381 maps that has been made
it's absolutely look at there's a
Walmart map someone made a Walmart map
a Walmart map oh my God
what's going on Cub
oh okay let me make sure that's all yeah
I need to erase those
yeah so I went through here and I
bookmarked some fun ones that we could
play with the community uh how how this
is gonna work chat is after we have
played a good amount of the year I think
Kings only uh able to do it for an hour
or two and solve got some stuff he got
to do too uh didn't mean cargo ain't
gonna jump over on some uh sendim you
know because we got some stuff for to
play on Damia
uh it's clear you gotta run and go do
some car stuff but after I finished my
car stuff my
[Music]
butt I thought I heard Cog for a second
he said hey
pop right there uh yeah I hear him out I
hear him now yo okay yeah
that's weird it's on my screen it still
says connecting the expert like it
wouldn't let me so yeah you're probably
self-corrected stuff soon all right all
right so people that want to join
like you know um the haters Halo slander
they was just holding you back for a
little bit
um
attention round we oh yeah
oh there's something in the water it's
in the water what's in the water the
water
well I need seven of these dudes rescue
training dogs
huh
[Music]
I have to unpack my [ __ ] Halo
controller because of this
no my right bumper on my like my regular
um Elite is bugging out
you know I drop on oh damn watch did
something with the left analog I keep
forgetting Halo one or the Halo what I'm
hurt
um the elite controllers get your money
back
yeah yeah you do that I think for sure
but I think that one I got from
Microsoft himself
yeah
yeah we are live though by the way so
you guys know that we are live yeah it's
cool
cares about us
all right
just making sure that you guys don't
know yeah no he's trying to protect us
so we're not out of pocket
he did the right thing how do you join
you send me a message
and I will make sure that you're not
psycho and then I will join and I will
send you in I will be filtered through
our our system you have to be vetted
yeah attic has to bet you we have a we
have a two-way verification you have to
send me a picture of a a of a clown
oh no really High Street
a lot of people disqualify right now
exactly
yeah
the King David says something about um
all right so he here
here is my uh gamertag so everyone uh
send me an invite uh a message in that I
thought that was gonna say something
else
here is my what is this snowball
launcher oh God the king got a snowball
launcher send me a message and I will
get you and uh
which you know my government's up on
that it doesn't matter at this point if
you guys don't know my name then you're
not you're not really paying attention
so
oh
I respect you brother
thank you I respect you
oh somebody gonna get hit in the mouth
with this snowball
to snowball oh my God where you at where
you at oh
hey yo you still playing for it yeah
yeah I'm trying to die I've been running
down or die
trouble in the mouth Fab
okay
stupid with a sword in the stomach
that's what she said
I'm dead
we're already starting again Batman
killed me
all right I gotta go let me go let me
get let me get all right get over there
to the game yeah you can join as a PC
Gamer uh we we we're not we're not in
the 360 area we got cross play
you guys got to send me a message
and then I will get you in here
they got to send me a message so I will
get them in here
I can't be too much more like
transparent than that
um attic said you gotta ride it in the
sky yeah
you definitely you know write me a
letter
four four Page Letter sending you a full
page letter
hahaha
somebody gonna get shot in the face
today
hello
I haven't played since this update so
this is something Well what we'll do is
we'll replace it the last time we played
it oh what we'll do is we will we will
start like uh something that that's fun
to play we won't really stick to too
much uh
yeah uh Jamaican entertainment
yeah I like Jamaica I like making it
he's a nice dude yeah he's happy boy
ducky
feel bad I'm missing out I love to go
against King get in ducky
yo yo
yo yo ducky man come on man pause we
ain't got to go against King my
God
so so many ways I could twist that joke
definitely yes yes
what's that you're ridiculous
Let's Twist that joke
so I I think I already know what the
first thing we're going to play just
just something everybody come on
come on hour ago
and accept it I get it oh oh here you go
he said said two times
where is it at
on your Xbox Live message well maybe
yeah
it says this is cool it says I'm already
you know what let me let me get myself
online so I can all right here comes the
harassment
thank you
there he goes we got him what's that
actually
right so I didn't see it
um just try to get notifications I hit
the Xbox Live button yeah
um
are you invisible that's probably what
it is I just sent it to him again
well let me try to send it to him in the
actual like menus now since he's
appearing online
foreign
we'll
go from there
I don't let
I'm kind of thinking we'll play
something uh fun the first time
something uh that you know we can have a
good time on
uh
see your face [ __ ] stop my book
stupid she wanna do stupid stuff man
stop it come here let me see your face
let's do this the first time I I like
this
I'm licking my fingers
oh shout out to Raiden blade Happy New
Year's Day Lord Daddy
winter update
get a new battle pass oh yeah okay
uh
so so that's how we're gonna do this
we're gonna individually go through one
of these all right because once
everyone's dead it's a wrap it it it's
done
it probably should have made this uh
free-for-all I don't even know if you
can make it this is Slayer Arena yeah
this is gonna be crazy this is the squid
game where uh the square gang uh one
where the platform will just disappear
on you and you'll fall through a word
yeah
yo they really did it
okay let's go Spartan over there
yeah we gotta check the glass the whole
solid gold spots
supposed to do you grab one of these you
grab one of those things over there
all right now you gotta drop on these
who's going first
oh right there
all right so
oh the jump is whack
oh I'm the only one left I hate this you
would ask wow
my favorite episode
yeah we gotta make
yeah
we didn't like it very long
kill each other in this part yeah that's
what that's wild
without that I think I'm gonna make the
response like three
oh
that's nothing how do you create that's
nothing what I've been seeing that is
absolutely nothing
let me find out how you change the the
respawns on here
are you stupid I am
done
all right so someone playing that live
service games have four legs
are you replying the Zeitgeist the
single player games
did you get in yeah
hey everyone I know it's podcast what's
up that's my man
we need people to switch around here
this is different we need a little bit
more what I gotta do we need one more
person who wants to jump in here we need
one person
we need one person keep getting in the
sky it's a wrap
so for the two-factor authentication
they can't jump inside our party
let me put my phone on mute this move
oh what about you can't smooth jump off
high and like jump on here
somebody jumped on stream oh that's fine
free your string could come with you
come on here
donate sounds horrible that's probably
why it does I'm like that just me it's
coming from my mic that's fine that's
fine jump in here high in life can wait
you bring your bring your views here
me
Connecticut
here we'll play one game
one down
oh my God all right so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna play one game so you
guys can understand
how this how this game play Works my bad
yeah just mute yourself when you're not
talking smooth and um do that I'm
streaming
just come on over here man don't worry
about that
don't worry about that hey forget what
you doing we can share Lively what's
your business to get your business
it'll be fine
oh they got a little Splat dude all
right all right come back
all right so
Game of Thrones
so yeah we are down we are down a person
stability patch
with a rocker yeah no it it just if the
person that took the if the person that
took the picture didn't do it right it
would do that
damn
they pushed chivalry in here
don't let them win it's capture the flag
whiskey
push up push up key
they're at the games oh there's like
it's down here stabbing them
what did he shoot me with oh they're
throwing grenades at the top
you got to go to the top to get them
so much
stop it
oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] he said no you're not
touching that I got him I got him
uh oh this is when you get the grenades
at here let's go
let's go we're going all the way
um
[Laughter]
we got a Super Chat wow
eight dollars Super Chat perfect timing
I was just falling asleep on night shift
happy birthday attic Lord's playing that
before Halo greatest PlayStation can't
come
grab that flag you can't go down foreign
look at all the swords just laying
everywhere they don't despawn
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God man
[Music]
it's hard to determine where it's hard
to determine where the Bots end and
where they start you know what I'm
saying yeah
[Laughter]
to throw it to the desk get him
yeah we're pushing up
King you're going to a forehead
King's about to get killed by like eight
people
get him y'all
are they cookies son and lunch meat
feelings free oh my God
here we go kicking the whip to the
castle Yeah
you know I do oh he slapped my head
over there okay to come outside all
right
oh I hear you I see you Dawn dog came up
no uh y'all after this uh we'll we'll
let other people join
no you know
[Laughter]
imagine this map at Big Team Battle with
turrets on the sides
oh the throwing grenades again
ah Kamikaze in your way
now let's let's wait let's wait let's
wait for them let's wait for them
everyone
yeah get that get that [ __ ] out of here
Don what you doing what you trying to do
how you come in here and try to take our
flag like that I ain't feeling that
everybody get in we're going all the way
the counterproof boys
hahaha
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh this is like everyone has an
overshield
[Laughter]
you can't do that
oh my God they're gonna win
today
don't let him get away
there you go the Bulletproof
thank you I'm gonna show you how to use
that hammer go go go go go oh my God he
killed us both don't let him get away
get that flag back
animals
I killed like 400 dudes yeah they all
run around with fast though
capitation
get out of here with that BS yeah yeah
you ain't got no Fest truck attention
what it is now
glitch you gotta package
who brought you home
they weak around the stomach
[Music]
wow around these stuff
[Music]
we can't believe we like what we we let
drunken ninjas score now we can't do it
another way
say yo that new king came out the bushes
[ __ ] get on get on call
yeah let's go to the house let him go to
the house I'm home don't
go go go
pull me straight into the door
don't stop for anything [ __ ]
keep going keep going
are you supposed to go inside
do you want me with the 10 super chat uh
Happy Birthday appreciate it
hey yummy blue eyes
everybody go boom
[ __ ]
yeah let me get that
all you gotta do is he next to the wall
what are you talking about you worry
about what I'm doing
all right upstairs
I love how the swords don't disappear
they're just everywhere
[Music]
there he is
yeah
oh they're pulling in on us
yeah yeah it don't matter I'm home don't
worry about it it's a keyhole
go go go go go go
keep going we're going all the way home
we're going all the way home
we're going all the way home
oh they got me thank you
if I get that ham out your hand you know
what it is
they can't be only one have a it can't
be only one happens yeah you know what
it is I get that hammer you know
that's an if for me
you know I always I racked up like 30
kills
get him
I need backup I got it you got it bro
you got it you got it
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
but you lost it 36
Earth man that that that hammer got some
crazy qualities in it man yeah I like it
that's why I use it
who got that hammer hammer
back to the building
why they got the why they got the fruit
in the middle of it
you hungry on your way
get get out of here oh the hammer went
off the board oh who's going hit oh man
look at all these swords
yes that is so beasty
characters the way I'm slicing these
dudes up
and push forward
pull back pull back they're about to
come at you with like 15 people pull
back
so it only needs one
which one is the AI the AI is effective
because there's like five of them guts
right in the guts
right in the giblets
I see you now you know what a word
only some
Kamikaze again we're back
man there's just so many I can't one
dude
[Laughter]
all right all right hey hey
little Let Them Fall for the distraction
let them fall for me and y'all just go
ahead check what you want yeah yeah
don't don't fall for the banana in the
terrible let's go
watch me
grenade we got what we want
they all fell back to the cribs
we're about to lose four minutes it's
all right
knock your nose loose
thank you thank you Jeeves
he looked kind of ashy I thought you got
better clothes my back yeah yeah you
know what my I'm always asked you know
how good
all right tow truck get me inside what
the hell
we're drunken Ninja
fruit
man there's just so many of them coming
through they're coming through they got
me boxed
they weak they're weak they got a sword
it no matter how weak you are
all right
he smashed everybody
there you go
get that flag Back Lean on that all
right all right all right
get in
kill him kill him
oh he killed me in midair
hi let's go baby decapitation
that's all I need is your hammer boy we
got two minutes to make something work
two minutes two minutes
oh my God they blocked it off you can't
get in there anymore
good job
I want everyone
oh my God first Brothers we gotta all go
at the same time
I don't care who has that hammer it's my
hammer
you oh man
[Laughter]
who happened with that car God bless
you killed me you know that right
keep pushing
push
in a turtle position
s
so that man king is a beast
oh
we'll deliver
he drove the whip each other
we could do this keep going
[Laughter]
[Music]
no matter what
all right all right send me send me
messages
send me messages guys I'll get you guys
in here we're going to probably play
like a big Team Battle if we get enough
people thank you baby
yeah I was wow that was some hilarious
[ __ ]
47 degrees
in Detroit oh he's just happened yeah
somebody need to stop playing Halo
that man need to go I need to go pro
I had I had 46 kills I got four oh uh
four triples and I got four overs uh two
overkills that's my partner in crime
right there let's look at the scoreboard
I got one grand slam one triple kill
it all right here's here's someone we
got him coming up in here
right here's where you guys send it
we're gonna start playing some of the
bigger stuff but we need more people
before we can play it
mm-hmm
yeah that force is crazy wow no I'm
telling you like that's nothing I'm
doing the light stuff right now
you did a damn good job love
you
stupid
that was on her watch I ain't giving
nobody no friends
oh live Supremacy
yeah now she going she did her job
every time I got in that thing it's like
he knew he's like at it going to drive a
car in here almost I'm a clip him the
moment he gets out worse
and then it's a good it's a goon packet
of them and you defended the castle by
himself hey I started back it up like
hold on hold on
I'm sending these invites guys I don't
know if you guys are getting them
they probably got that over shield in
that hammer uh-uh I would have stayed in
that castle beat the hell out of it
I got you drunken all right we need one
more person one more person for a five
on five
scarecrow oh yeah I'll send another one
he said can you set them again
yes I got you homie I'll send you one
too
foreign
so what was the point like when you're
on there are you fighting are you just
trying to get across you're just trying
to try to get across like I guess I
guess you could fight too I guess it
wouldn't matter keeping you from behind
yeah and then it was a fight if you fall
right yeah
that's crazy
all right so let's find one they have
the red light green light too yeah yeah
it's on you guys want to try that they
got the Star Wars
map they got a Star Wars map on here
it's it's it's it's absolutely Bonkers
like it's just crazy what they're doing
with this yo I I gotta say though like I
understand why if this had been ready at
launch bro it's a different story it's a
different story
oh no I know what we play all I can say
is
somebody's launch is today
yes
that is true
that is true
we're gonna see what's which 70 game
really matters most
exactly some some kid getting this under
their Christmas tree next week and it
yup that's it is there it's their launch
day that's true
they just got this series [ __ ] ax
they're smiling all right how many we
got here one three they got all those
games all right we'll rock with this
this is crazy
no no this is crazy space assault reach
it's pretty much Star Wars Battlefront
brought back where you do the like you
have to blow up each other's like
certain parts on each other's ship you
have to protect each other
we do gotta try to burial caught one two
just to see how we look oh damn oh my
goodness I didn't even know it was a
Mario Kart one yeah they got a battle
card in there
treasure
that's the power of the 12 teraflops
where's that though I can't yeah
but this is these are the modes that'll
bring over the fortnite players that are
just all about fortnite the young kids
yeah like this
don't show them this shaking [ __ ] yeah
yeah
dude
yo I'm impressed by like how good the
engine is something else fly wants this
is mine oh we gotta fly over
there
see Chris fine I'll be effective
immediately oh I jumped out on accident
I don't even remember how to get it that
dick
I don't know who following me
how you get out the hangar oh okay
oh
there's a Banshee get the Banshee don't
let him out
got him
it's the person to elevate
a uh
it's a right bumper right bumper and
left bumper oh my God
oh
yeah
guys you guys let someone went in and
just blew up everything
man I went in their base I was roughing
people up
it's fine we nearly got Star Wars but
that's actually a New Concept though
yeah let me see Mario Brothers
me okay I got you
actually let's do this one and then
we'll do Mario Brothers I'm actually
curious if this works very well
I promise you talking to ksrt settings
regards salute
that's a reset you can switch to lock
all Rockets
yeah I was listening to you show
who isn't buying
it they were kicking the Tiger
I gotta find the uh
popular modes I have to find the boat or
one for the popular modes they got um
I haven't seen a Mario Kart on here is
it have you seen it
no princess castle the castle the Mario
Brothers Castle
okay we'll do that then that's fine
popular Maps
mode Slayer I'm thinking my girl cooking
food upstairs I texted I said man those
eggs be taking a long time
are you playing with me right now
you don't mess with a hungry dude you
don't that's that's evil you don't do
that
when she came down with that platinum
and them eggs
that's what's up delicious
no no no she didn't put it in mango stop
separate without a mask
but sweets we plant this pause
what's up with some um avocado and then
what what we'll do after we play a
couple more is we'll start playing like
older maps that they've remade like and
they've re-enhanced it too like Blood
Gulch they've done a newer blood
coaches oh
Mario 64 remake wow why the tree look
better here
are we all gonna spot in one area
I
think uh okay what is this
it's attrition too keep that in mind
we're playing on nutrition
Commando hell no
[Music]
you know the trees look hilarious you
know somebody got lost
some idiot is in the couch get them
go get em going in the castle and get
that dude it's really good
yo the inside of the castle is lit
yo somebody got wide fragrance for
MasterChef what's going on in here
go upstairs here follow me Carl we gotta
go upstairs
oh they're coming in they're coming in
don't let them
oh
[Music]
people upstairs
the reason I picked attrition because we
want to get through a bunch of it and we
can't like play like standard games look
they there's like if you look there
there's a there's pipes like these green
pipes that you could jump on it at
teleports you just like it does in Mario
yo you stupid
Jessie's got up a gun are you stupid
wait these pipes do something yeah you
jump in them
yo
they rocking the front of the house
actually work like Mario Brothers
we don't got lies either
I'm out of lives
starting
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know I just saw somebody
got sniped out there everybody got body
crazy
foreign
oh my God someone take the BR out of
drunken Ninja
[Music]
I'm up here with you fly don't run like
a [ __ ] fly I'm up here with you I
killed the Titan yes
Don't Run Fly we got this
they got the guns up there don't leave
the don't leave Peach's castle they got
the guns
you have a kill you was sick to Beat It
did it
drunken ninja there's other people
coming up
come on
I like that
he was with big yammy
why is the Privacy jump in the
available
why are we uh why am I out of life
somebody wasted their lives
oh I got killed by rocket launcher
but I gotta sit out after I did so much
two on three
go
get it there
somebody go around the other way
yeah you got that hammer what you scared
of okay
you probably used up my life
we got sham guard
let's go
see you that you wow I see what you
doing for
one on Three
pack for the devil degree how are you
looking how you snitching oh there you
go
what was just a it's a DC unit
switch guns
get it with that rocking lot today
and unfortunately
I'm just amazed about the creativity
things you can make that look actually
like the product
I don't like sharing lives with people
I'm gonna mute for a second I'll make a
phone call all right
let's play I'm not this one I'm not a
fan of of these people get a hold of my
life
the reason I'm the reason I'm playing
attrition is because I I don't want
these games being mad long because I
want to get through a bunch of these
Maps
if you don't stop
acting like you do you was gonna kill me
I saw you and I killed you
I'm back you had a hammer that you
didn't switch and hope for the best I'm
sorry but but you if you were the person
with the hammer his Shields was gone you
could have just switched to your pro
your secondary and shot him
whoever had the Hammers suck
Ed on that
oh
you said don't do that
don't do that damn
I got got all types of extra stuff I
want to bash him in the head
I said King David's highly violent he's
different
very aggressive
that guy's different
you guys are ridiculous
be careful he's a murderer
this is the next map
wow
remember when you make it there
and you get the case look how crazy Cog
looks like
my whole check Cog look rich
my sporting is ashy as hell
oh someone shot me with something yeah
tell me this isn't crazy that they put
this in here like yeah that's wow
oh I got shot with some are you
yeah look the nuke's in the bottom too I
like what I see drunk Adventure
you know what that gravity hammer
available oh about a bullets
man
through
it's been so long since I uh
oh you can revive people
oh
ow ow ow
you can revive people guys keep that in
mind oh you can't oh
oyster
let me stop your message put that work
in them put that word I told you you
ain't got that overshoot is different
play Halo
this map is fun though it's very well
done
go get out of the layout
you body the dog
bulletin's hot
we're not downstairs
back for dead that was good that was
good that was your first kill surprise
no sneaky Pinky
keep your eyes off my goodies stuff
oh get me up Carlton right there beside
you
hit you with the eye bullet
get me down there
they got verticality
you twisted you was looking at me enemy
response depleted yeah got bad bad's
done someone protect his body we playing
this like Trials of Osiris
got drunken ninja he's out of here
addiction
who shot you in the house with that
pistol pistol worth S7 snipers
revive deny get out of here with that
yummy is that your body
I'm being very toxic
I'm gonna sit on these two bodies I'm
gonna sit on these two bodies
[Music]
yeah welcome to Nuketown
welcome
to Nuketown
I'm gonna spit out my juice you guys are
ridiculous
yo I gotta go I'll be back I gotta um do
the car picture thing can you can you do
can you play one more
I'm driving out here with no Collision I
gotta go
this is
I already I already started it send me a
message so I know who wants to join next
time what up Hector
happy birthday yeah yeah that Megan said
that fall out Jay I'm Ill on that map
found the map look at that
that kind of reminds me of something you
would see in Destiny to be honest with
you yes
the active verticality
over Paul says happy birthday
appreciate it
yo he said Carlton like a samurai that
came out the jewelry store in fact
that's how heavy Carl's suit is because
it's all gold
singled up
my books
let's go
oh what's this this body Warfare It's
Nuketown it's modern work
scene see you oh they got the bus and
all that
okay
really did that
oh yeah me all right yeah me oh we're
down by two
oh they got their advantage yeah
we'll rebalance the team after this
oh it's permanently it ain't nobody
well I can't really
can I force them no hold up one of them
needs to switch over salt can you switch
over yeah it sucks switch to our team
I mean he's on the phone like that all
right hopefully he can hear us though I
think he said yeah switch over
let's go
Liberty yes
let's go
[Music]
let's go someone said Microsoft needs to
buy Activision to dodge copyright
strikes and Forge
right
you got an unfair Advantage four people
on your team drug Edition don't do that
you know what happens when I see you oh
I missed that man I
don't be doing no bagging
uh soft still hasn't jumped over lemons
yet
yes stack line up happy birthday young
Gunner appreciate it okay I'm back what
happened we lost let me say happy
birthday at it I know I said appreciate
it so they're they're up by one now
because lemon joined our team
and you kill him let me know you see him
let me know
but that's my god oh they're by you
lemon there's two right there second
floor second floor lemon today he's not
my guy yeah I'm fighting one right now
to get up there which I'll be waiting
for [ __ ] one is that
let's go
just kill sham guard
got killed
yeah see I was fighting y'all be and
then okay trucker
I don't throw no grenades don't do that
please
[Music]
again
so if somebody don't kill God
oh
I'd like to erase this from the record
book
no uh lemon we just we just played a map
that was megaton from Fallout 3.
that's the fact
that is a whole thing
I personally don't think that score is
indicative of my play all right now
we'll play something fun now we'll play
something fun while I wait for you guys
to get in that's the two big excuse
[Laughter]
excuse
oh that's the real ties oh the real ties
the Sham God shame God oh tip that
tipped over the technology hi happy
birthday Xbox gonna have a show January
oh we got a technical exclusive E3 in
June will be out partying yes brother
good I'm looking forward to seeing you
still coming through oh deal going
through 2023 okay hell play two possibly
I don't know nothing I don't know
nothing I'm listening to you
let me
let me build it too
all right Nova bond is some fun
infection match
thanks Rob you just got this looks like
Toy Story version of the Toy Story
version of Nicktoons Newtown oh bro look
at the creativity the engine though yeah
no you should have seen the Super Mario
Bros and the chivalry boy really
impressed me
all right um
this should technically work I I I put
it to
play exactly how it's supposed to I
don't know though but we'll see we're
playing Red Light Green Light
oh [ __ ] oh no
yeah they got squid game baby let's go
oh no
appreciate it Tim dog you should jump in
here if you're not busy Tim
yes he said he was raking leaves
get your green thumb on tracks let's go
go
this is this sport is super impressive I
haven't played Halo and since
the updates
this is crazy launch
Ed
clearly it messed up it didn't give me
the one it was supposed to I mean when
when you get when you get to the end of
that red light green light sometime it
don't it don't well sometimes it don't
what's the name it don't give you a
winner
later I gotta get you guys back in here
oh we gotta leave we leave her oh okay
so all right leave it in there take that
bite yeah right after my double kill you
see that if you kill me it don't count
because we you know what I'm saying
I gotta make sure I'll take that assist
I take all that assists thank you wait a
minute
wait we leaving what we doing yeah we're
leaving
all right so everyone send me another
invite if you was in here the last time
because I have to get everyone back in
here
we said the invite again for some reason
I can't find a chance
Pew shooters red light green light
I gotta make sure the mode is the right
mode
everybody leave
our key to me
you're gonna get any score three
creeping
you can come in here uh arguing if you
want to
damn
all right let me get back come on back
don't do that
it's disrespectful
wait a minute did you just respawn to
come get me come on back stay away from
you Montgomery are you guys gonna join
are you still fighting
oh I I thought oh my bad yeah you are
averaging
oh my bad oh my [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's what I thought it was gonna
snatches
they don't have those tools yet
all right I'll give you guys a couple
yes [ __ ] Jay just send me an invite I
got you chicken Jake
oh Porsche Power here
on my team and then then I'ma look for
dragon and then after this we'll start
doing some big Team battles because
there's enough people
yeah see if we get Porsche Power here
thanks I'll bring one of my goons for
you drunken Ninja
leaving
what's going on back don't get excited
because you killed me once but I killed
you three times in fact my bad
you know you're my destiny
connoisseur so you know what I'm saying
I gotta I gotta put some respect on your
name right now you know oh yeah that's
the guy no I know
oh sicario what up
if you can
no off my mind what's your that's your
that's your gamer tag
oh I know why it didn't pop up for me
because I'm appearing offline yeah
but the the invite didn't pop for me
yeah for some reason it didn't pop some
time yeah it says the muffin the Muff
one and mon is his game attack don't
start I won't get my man yo we just lost
mad people
everyone's gone do they have um
yeah yeah they got a bunch but I want to
do this red light green light first and
then yeah let's do red light relay first
and then we get you when somebody wins
Red Light Grid Knight addict I don't
know if they fixed it but you gotta uh
you gotta just start the match over
because once you get to the end it does
I mean I guess since we got enough
people we can go just straight into like
a big Team Battle we don't I do want to
kind of see red light green light though
it's dope
let me just let's just see it let's just
see what okay let's go next one
and they made the doll exactly the same
thing yeah
oh I got to see this
oh they said the gang crash that's the
biggest issue they they still gotta fix
but the the glitches in this game man
so okay I got you I got you guys okay
people were trying to get back in
because their game crashed yeah
bet you guys are on PC I'm just saying
ain't none of my business
why are they gonna be on PC they kicked
me right out
let's go
all right we'll wait for solve and wait
like a minute for other people to
message and then we're gonna
start it
oh
yeah cards can you see the ducky early
already saw off Wallace the new Duncan
wow I did not see that
he's a beast he is a beast all right
solve you back up
Rod Castro salon
I already know
okay okay yeah you got you got it okay
by Larry we're gonna start it guys
and then after this we're going to do a
couple big Team battles I want to do a
big Team Battle on remake maps from Halo
3 because there is a sand trap is back
yeah whatever there's a bunch of them
it's a fortune all its Glory
let's talk about that Oculus experience
I had last night
I was in a movie theater with graph
passing popcorns and pumping
oh wait hold up
yeah he doesn't play Halo but he said
hey y'all just taking a clip to get my
friend hope you guys are right oh okay
he would have got oh you lucky drunken
ninja my goon had to do something lucky
yo yo yeah
this is fire
I hope they I hope they fixed it though
to announce the winner so she just lets
off on you no you blow up
he is Fred fellas
Teeth Red all right oh I gotta wait out
I gotta wait she could have never turn
green oh run run
get run oh my God
[Laughter]
so if you lose you still get the player
I don't even spread it upside up top if
you lose
you just chill up tops okay so you can
see okay so I can spectate you yes
oh they still green they look oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God he tried
to pick Around The Rock
oh okay we can walk the whole length of
the thing so that's awesome
up top you could just kind of like
spectate and see how the rest of them do
it that's funny
when yet that ain't me uh I'll let for
the rest to go through before I already
started somebody crossed yeah yeah
nobody crossed I wish I could zoom in
and see their name
they need to add that for that she
almost got me you know what I hear me
all right hey guys how's it going look
how scared of it is
beyond the grave
you baby
two or three two oh
someone they said you ought to win oh I
got third I got third
round
I can't see her
that's why you got to get from behind
The Rock
look at the four whoa oh oh she cheated
I'm Petty
[Music]
did you Buckle me
oh I just let's just hear the explosions
in the background
oh she's smiling yeah
girl you gotta turn
up
got me out of pocket
see you to give you a pass right there
[Music]
who is
this
right
who made it with you baby they need to
let us see the names all right that's my
baby yeah I already know he gotta put in
the code to create it right right yeah
right so then from there it could really
be funny look they're playing soccer up
there the losers are playing soccer
I didn't make as much at the time God
damn you oh Dutcher
damn bro
there you go yo I'm behind The Rock
yo who got body I saw this
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go
turn
yo she go
green light one two three
[Laughter]
good
okay
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go
go go she real generous with it
and she gonna turn on me I knew
I'm watching y'all play the squid game
[ __ ] that's just this is beautiful
[Laughter]
yeah all right now since we have this
many people let's try the other one
again now the one where you jump to
school
what's that
oh I got first let's go
I got first it said I got first on my
end we all got everybody on Mexicans
first don't take my phone
game there is no first it's definitely
yeah
for life oh they tricked me they tricked
me
you gotta be she starts out red that's
why you gotta be careful
oh
bodies everywhere
okay
so is it just like
yeah
oh she on her BS oh here we go here we
go
I wish they'd let us control her when
we're dead up here
oh that'd be awesome well I'm in here
sweating
[Music]
[Music]
uh oh we can play soccer while we up
here yeah
oh I ain't never been up here okay
he's almost there
Yoshi wow look he's not even running
anymore nope screw that like this is
slow and steady slow and steady that's
you that's you Buffalo
okay wait who's that soft yeah
they all defeated
yo cause the thing is you gotta stay
looking at it because it because it's
not a sniper rifle like an actual show
it just as you move and you're behind
already then you're done you gotta you
gotta listen for
you gotta listen wow that's crazy hard
you must use the force young Padawan
all right so let me
we're gonna do the uh the one where they
uh that we jump on the thing yeah the
paddles oh the platform yeah four guys
let's go oh God no no we're doing the
squid game The Last squid game one
oh yeah
who going first
well he definitely fixed it because like
when we first was playing it like three
weeks ago it didn't have no ending
together
to Darnell said y'all was playing soccer
in Valhalla
your dog was laughing
great girl currently you can't Crouch no
I'm an amazing piece of workforge is
when they had the campaign Ai and
possibilities yeah it's gonna be crazy
it's crazy
I got the rock favors to see who go
first I ain't going first
switch the map to that other one
foreign
happy birthday
um attic I appreciate it
oh shorty it's your birthday
we have that in common
oh yeah oh you too you're after it's my
birthday oh happy birthday
Jesus
was the only one who remembered I bet I
got caught up
and does it come up in Twitter because
if it comes on Twitter I'll see you have
to watch it
I know now you guys I won't be roughy I
don't even know my mom's birthday so
yeah wow Facebook man Facebook's the one
that tells me Facebook tells me Facebook
Facebook
let's go
no
I like they got us in the warm-up room
so what we got to grab off the shelf
what's this we gotta grab the uh the
little bombs that's on
oh so oh okay okay
mad aggressive yo all right who's going
first
oh
yeah
that look good oh
wait oh
all right now get up get out of here
all right so you next okay
you know what to do I I trust your
judgment
I guess it's not that
oh
yo this is your captain speaking welcome
to the losers around please
on your right let's go
all right I took I took the initiative
it's your turn now it's your turn I did
it last time you do it this time
probably not oh no not that one all
right
50 50.
oh my God oh my God okay
[Laughter]
that's crazy
oh that's also his glitch you know and
he no no no no he has to um he has to
fix it
that's how Square game was right God
[ __ ] got you guys again there was no
soccer level on that last one he added
that later he added something to do
while you watch it while you watching
okay but look I took the first one that
took one for the team I'm watching now
okay
killed
so no one can start the event until you
pick up the bulletproof okay
I think you guys got this
he doesn't got that but we got that yeah
oh no okay
wait a minute who jumped back yeah
somebody jumped back I said you're a
straight sucker don't you love how they
do don't you don't you love how they
don't tell us our names for that
specific reason
oh
yeah yo can you man I like you if you
partially missed I like you
oh man I got decisions to make
nice way
why'd you push me off
[Laughter]
all by myself
do they die
all right here it is the diagonal Cog
wanted you guys to get up there so yeah
I knew what he was gonna do
the right way so you could die later
Tom told you guys the right way so you
can kill him later
okay
all right let's go next
oh two more
you can't you can't long jump this one
hey we'll try it one more time we'll try
it one more time and then we'll go to
bed
no don't listen
like that was straight up the only
reason you told him the right way so
they could be your guinea pigs going
forward
sacrificial Lambs disrespectful out here
go nope not that one not that one
whoa whoa whoa
what's going on
yo he need cows look what he's doing I'm
not playing with him
man this dude is straight up ballsy he's
just jumping back to back
oh he's going all the way besides that
one
I was doing good I was doing good at it
that was you love it yeah now I'ma wait
for you guys
yo is it the same rule with only more
than two if three people no no
all right next person
no I think it's good man I'm not playing
no more Moses I'm in my house I mean I
would go there but it's two of y'all
I just I made this jump all right
if you come back no oh everyone can be
on it it's fine
y'all gonna say that number four no come
on seriously
so they saw me all right
okay so Carl took the phone it's now
your turn
it's your turn so whoever jumped to This
One automatically knew to jump to this
one because Cog died yeah you jumped
here too he's salty as hell I said y'all
must be bored if y'all playing this
trash
what you want Jump games are better with
friends
[Music]
you guys go
yeah
go go I jumped on this one
all right all right that's fair it's
definitely this one
I know it's me it's me he died bro who
is it it's me
for your birthday
oh
okay
David got the sound effect yeah
how did he even beat this that's crazy
yeah this is insane man that's insane
that they made this show
it's quick game all right let's let's
let's jump off yeah let's do another
move
um
shout out to them I could even make
these tools crazy
this is pretty dope I like it
you know the dude that jumped back
yeah that was me
Odell birthday boy let's go
oh it's it's making us do all the other
rounds
oh Stu Jersey attic setting up today
just keep saying tie over and over again
okay let's just exit it it's probably
gonna make us do all the rounds and then
do it oh damn okay how many rounds is it
how many rounds is it 10 I think
yeah we could just leave we just leave
the game
yeah
I'm about to send invites again though
yeah did we send an invite all right
everybody we're doing big Team battles
now all right so Aurora Wolfe
pit Lord Mike it's Alex birthday yes
it's called Birthday streaming the title
it says it
damn empty
all right I don't like hearing myself
talk so uh someone's gonna fix that
whose background is that
I can assure you it ain't mine probably
me yeah it ain't me it's probably gonna
have to volume up on mine that's fine
just turn yeah Forte remember for 36
months gaming 14. I almost been a boy oh
you read that earlier yeah crazy
I mean uh hey look is this doing
something weird
so
I'm thinking do we play an old map
it's whatever you want bro someone says
take it back what up
we doing that thing tonight yeah let's
go I think want to do it after I don't
want to do it right after
I'm down
I think I'll see you in it let me see
you don't want to do it too
you can't you think she's because you
have one you can't host anymore
that's even better like that bookmark
I didn't realize you could have more
than one say I thought it was just you
got that one save and that was it yeah
I want to play but no you're good bro I
don't want to delete this this thing
because oh that was the one that we did
with your bosses yeah oh yeah I see what
you said no you're good I didn't want to
delete that one you know like what if
they come back it's gonna be off yeah I
mean it's gonna be hard for them because
their schedules are so crazy well yeah I
just didn't want to like a backup excuse
yeah he deleted by accident
about me I Blame You
yeah that's fine it ain't gonna affect
me exactly
as long as it doesn't affect you no no
it definitely doesn't affect it
he wants an invite so this yeah Steve
Henry yeah yeah we're doing this no Mark
move on it's in here too okay for sure
coagulation yeah Reed attic if you do
end game instead of leave games yeah I
already read the party with you okay
cool cool steve Henry with the advanced
Halo infinite tips
to do one of the car racing ones yeah he
couldn't find it I wanted to do that too
there's a cart racing one oh they got
everything in this squiggan chivalry
all type of joints
oh I might have to
jump back into this yeah download the
draw
I have it I just don't I haven't played
it
the only two games that I've been
playing lately is uh midnight Suns
check killed me with this desk
I couldn't play I couldn't play the
midnight Suns for uh for a minute
because
there was a the game this is glitch I'm
waiting for them to fix
oh yeah
so
in Marvel midnight Suns
you get to a certain point like you can
only do specific things all right right
they just dropped the patch they dropped
to drop the patch for that oh man Jeff
the patch actually it's yesterday
yeah yeah I I beat Midnight science it's
awesome to me like oh man I've got a dad
I'm going to beat it it's just been
taking so much time seven minutes 37
hours oh after
37 minutes I'm like that's a speeder in
there oh I was gonna say like you can't
even do 30 seconds
we need one more person we need one more
person we need one more all right who
else do we get we got way hit we got
MacBook no we just we we have six on six
now
oh God
okay all right so let's go
birthday stream
let's get it
might have to pop a cup I have to pop a
cupcake with a candle in it for my
brother let's go no
let's go Chuck [ __ ] say yo Phil online
[ __ ] in the Empire
hey yo are you gonna shut up
go do that
I'm gonna back slap Happy Birthday
addict shout out to slo-mo yeah another
year yeah
what are we playing
um
attic at the cradles beard and I'm over
here with the uh Grizzly Adam's beard
it's a stability
shout out to the no introduction on my
screen yeah yeah that's a setting that's
a setting that you have to do I guess
they didn't do it
shout out to whatever that was
this is a reimagining too like they've
made changes to it oh it's like crazy
make sure y'all get the vehicles
a coach different version
that's a that was a good one
back in the day
oh yeah
I don't think I've seen it
eagle versus cobra
thank you
oh we're taking heavy oh somebody got
the big ticket somebody yeah why are you
running tank versus tank let's go
get out of there drunken Ninja
[Applause]
why are you worried about my course this
is what happened
your attic I'm coming with the same
oh they got me man oh hold on I see
something
grenades that means you close enough to
take these Rockets I see them oh he out
did I ain't messing with you living
here
no that tank was behind me wait he's
about to let me go crazy yeah facts
don't get the flag
no I'm just making sure before I said
something inappropriate yes yes thank
you
oh my God man they get me up out of
there to the moment I get on appreciate
your service
oh man this this is taking it back man
[ __ ] out of here
he said who the hell is
turkey
I got rid of that [ __ ] you drunken
Ninja
I killed him I killed him I killed the
Banshee you killed him already dead
oh y'all out here trying to do me return
look they both chasing me down
that turbo life
oh my God that tank got me man drunken
ninjas in the tank he's in the tank
where are you running he would be in the
tank
he would be in the tank
enemy carrier has revealed it's about
the back I got to go
get away
sorry bro
let's go
whoa what the whoa they have a driving
difficulties yeah they have a job with
difficult to get them
[Music]
nice bring it back bring it back home
bring it back home we need a vehicle you
got to get a vehicle yeah
I'm bringing one right now
return that
oh my God the flag's up on the side nice
flag's in the middle lights in the
middle blue team get the flag
I wish I wasn't I wish I didn't have
that Lagos flag up they got a tank right
by it yeah
oh and he just caught that mill near
let's go
yo why would Prince respawning what's
going on here with this buyer
this is crazy let's go down let's go
that's you over there all right
let's go
all right I'm over here in the tank
helping get that tank out of there no I
killed the tank drunken Ninja's dead
and that the band she's dead and that's
dead
yeah
[Music]
muffin Man's dead
we'll handle handles son I'm ready
someone hurry up and get that flag cause
right there
bro
um
somebody got y'all flagged
yeah
running around with the cookies
turn that turn that nice
get out of here
oh they got me finally man
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
my mission was still completed even
though I got broadside
are you not running in my face
somebody you're here
yes we need to handle something but do
we need to hear them let's go
ah
where was that taken
yeah it takes forever
oh let me catch again
Little Ghost battle going on
the ghost behind our base yo he think
he's slick
how many flags I'm just chilling
watch out he's behind you with that
ghost with the junk all right
man I'm getting hit by two things get
him get him get him get him get him get
him
there you go get him get him get him
don't let him hop away oh he hopping
away in the broad daylight what's going
on
they take his back they take it back
they take his back
man
slots at it
[Laughter]
last shot at it I I'm a few seconds
behind so I just saw that sniper shot
okay
hop in carrier let's go wait a minute
look at these clowns look at this now
don't run now
[ __ ] don't run down
look at that okay
yeah
let's go
fully basketball let's go baby
go go go go
outside
go
keep going you go you go you go ah
get your ass out of there a whole lot
let's go let's go but you hold on what
y'all doing here oh flag and go go go go
and go let's go go I got you back keep
going keep going you're gonna do this
oh yeah
keep going with that flag yo they say
I'm a problem out here let's go
now I'm really putting some work
back no further than that all right
I returned it we're good
I did my job guys
oh
oh I hit with that ghost
oh Danny got a rocket
oh they got a oh they got a tank too
okay yeah where you going what are you
doing what's up oh sorry moving you're
drunken Linda let me introduce myself
properly let's go wait a minute what you
doing put that flag sorry I'm back I'm
going away with that Bob is sleeping
we can't pay the security guard
give me your rockets by doing acting up
behind the scenes
the tank got me they got a tank and I'll
spawn we gotta It's gotta be a collector
I know I know
you know what
a warthog
oh my God
shout out to The One Super Chat by Aura
wolf streams one dollar appreciate it
babe
it's a wrap yeah ain't nothing we can do
it's not a Dev
IL because the flags are in play
hey you know what I'm Petty like 50 Cent
whoever running over here sniping I got
something for you oh no no no no
all right I wanted that homicide it's a
wrap for me thank you
yo I'm out fellas AJ happy birthday
brother appreciate it man I will see
y'all tomorrow
says happy birthday as well she was like
I should have taken him away though
I think one saw Blaze will be tie again
though
yeah
let me see if anyone else wants to join
you gotta send me a message Steve
Henry send me a message
come on
I don't know if they were that broken
but I was doing quite a bit of damage
with that uh with that scorpion when I
had it
gonna break her guardian
Mario Brothers
it's crazy
eternity Rainbow Road yes they do
Savage
armor hole
all right let's pick some ones that they
claim is for well we got 6v6
uh yeah Kmart shoppers
away
no it's 76.
all right
like some some of these maps are wild
looking
husky ready walls
sorry wrong
the basketball
I know these
was that a Minecraft map
the login
you know actually let's play
I got a fun map we could play on
thank you
X again
all right I gotta use the bathroom real
quick guys
okay go for it
have you heard from sin
I have not
number one on cloud streaming number two
on Console only behind Minecraft number
two on PC engagement is extremely strong
for a single player only title
like I like the game I like the way I
like the gameplay there's something
about the game that makes me nauseous
which game
higher life do you have a motion blur on
or off I have no idea it's whatever the
default is I think it's on I always have
to turn motion blur off because I I do
not like motion blur like I couldn't
even Watch Sinister play the game it was
making me I I watched him for about as
long as I could play before and I had to
stop so he got to this point a little
bit further than the point that I got
and we both was like yeah we're done
I really like that I I beat it I like
the games
it is
one more person yeah
yes slow-mo come on in here
61 Metacritic or whatever and it's fun I
I it's entertaining it's funny it's fun
it's just
I got I gotta check to see if that
motion blur is on
I don't know what it is like if it's not
the motion blur I have no idea because
it made me it was making me sick you'll
be emotion sickness
huh
that's what it is
Sonic Sonic Adventures on Dreamcast did
that to me oh yeah yeah
I don't think I played that on on
Dreamcast I was too busy playing shenmue
Soul Calibur now
pillow
yeah you can also charge turned on the
sensitivity on your camera movement
yeah turn it down I know in some games
appreciate it emotion sickness like
sickness
yeah the movement of the screen
how's it going fellas
good job
chilling chilly
we're playing capture the flag
and I I gave everyone an AR and a br so
no no complaining because you don't have
a br
it's the BR bro I like a pistol
shot shot shot shot shot shot go
to the flag
oh this community is creative that's
what I'm talking about yeah
hold on why am I nice sporting suit look
dirty
I'm not supposed to look like that oh
this look wow oh this is fine
remember this
oh this is nice yeah I remember this oh
wow what stage is this
it's called facing worlds
God damn it I thought to be aggressive
somebody in the air already
oh this reminds me
what the hell
there's so many man what the hell is the
action
you said where's the accident
I woke up
I woke up to three people in my face
all the actions in the air
all right yo they got three dudes in our
face three dudes one got the flag at two
in front of me
yo we'll be at
them you know what I could play yeah
yeah we got to take care of some of
these shoes
for me Captain James Teague
oh you thought you thought it was sweet
out here huh now you dead y'all remember
y'all jumped me right
come out
how do we get out of here
oh no it's up it's up never mind
I'm in the soldier wait a minute I'm not
interfere with the recipe yo that's what
I said that's why I was like where
they're asking them
oh he got you got a attic just left me
on this planet
you gotta jump down you're on the
section yeah we gotta get off flat back
why you got Rockets got Rockets now I
got Rockets let's go if I jump down I'm
going down
somebody want that smoke
I guess
oh yeah here right here man you gotta
hold that [ __ ] you got let's go let's
try to return our flag
even though it's gonna be useful but I'd
rather take it than y'all take it
wait a minute I can't even move this
tank from this area yo listen
cause the Muffin Man The Muffin Man
it's a beautiful looking map it's got to
know where the hell to go
make sure that slide doesn't reset
yo they got vehicles on here you can't
move because it's stuck oh wait a minute
you tripping over here
all right let's go
oh word that's what we doing
you stay in the vehicle buddy
and the best take attic down drunken
it's a
man it took two banshees on my ass to
take me
yeah they definitely tagged him I'm
looking for something to kill them right
now
I don't like this
fly down here get with that bench and
Jackie like Grand Theft Auto I promise
you
oh so they say it because of space
crazy
I like the way this map looks it's just
God
Is Wild
who put this bag
I'm a sicario
for the advantage
is this
I don't even know what this is
I'm stuck again oh my God
it's like weird way out
wow
look like this one this is this is made
like the Borg ship this is crazy
oh yeah
it makes sense this does not
um
creatives
yeah I'm different I like the color
palette they use there yes yeah this is
crazy hell yeah it looks amazing yes it
does the play on map designs
what's good
all right
is that the buffing Mom
oh is that him
get a sniper rifle
oh Rocka stop running over there trying
to kill y'all
wow he survived two grenades and shots
and then I get killed from somebody else
what's up
wow
this stage reminds me of something you
know what being that I've seen you get
smoked up there I'm gonna mind my
business
they're drunk and I see who you at Dog
and I mocked him he's in that Tower up
top
I got a double head shots
let's go
I'll take those numbers
Todd did you see the uh new uh
VR environment thing
oh it's awesome it's awesome that joint
looks amazing
it's awesome yes sir I downloaded it
yesterday
um
yes please
man I didn't know where that shot was
coming from slow mo came out absolutely
nowhere
damn man we're about to lose again just
because we can't
get to the uh the base what is the point
of these these race down low you can't
go anywhere yeah
all these damn stuff on the map but you
can't even get them out of there
but I ain't downloaded like I was just
asking
oh damn
oh I made it oh okay
available
look at this look at these two vehicles
RV look at these look at these Savages
look at them look at them that's pure
Savages
am I
you're nice
okay let's play play
time to play play
a shot take that fly back
wait a minute who up here sniping again
oh oh my God you can get up there so let
me come up here and see you now let me
come see you
no don't run no no no keep that same
confidence you was doing with nobody
I know you're not talking yeah
[Applause]
down let's go
Verizon
oh no no no no no we don't do that oh no
we're not doing that oh
oh yeah clear that flag let's go
revealed theyself back today
I don't know no more Tower sniping for
you yeah
stop doing this
I'll take that
attic is that you up in that yeah
yo this map this mad vertical
oh I found that sniper rifle though I
sure did y'all I found it
all right lemon let's
let's show them what ASP already means
in this house those bags that's a fact
F-35 thank you they in trouble now
that was real dominant before we need
somebody to come get these flags we got
y'all out here we got y'all
he don't know where to go with it but
that's all right we don't kill enough
until you figure it out oh they
destroyed my vehicle
yeah
you're crazy
let's go find that way oh they got they
got their own air
thank you
that banshee's gone
what in the hell are you waiting for
I got it now
okay
I don't even know why you running with
that flag
I
I I I
it's a Teleport
give me that vehicle yeah
get that dude don't let him score
teleports people retrieve that retrieve
that don't let don't let them score
I'm on it I'm on it where y'all going we
got going oh yeah
because I can set all paced it's all our
base
go to the air we need the air
[Music]
yeah I was looking for a vehicle right
now but they gone teleporters guys this
is teleporting oh what's going on okay
what the hell is this wait a damn minute
oh I see what you're doing I see what
you're doing already already in the
vehicle
how'd I get down here
let's go
oh
yo you you ain't you ain't no good bro
but I'm with you
oh damn go down go down let's get that
damn it I pushed the wrong button
someone's got our our flag I see what
you was doing I see what you was doing
with that winged Bandit I see you we
gonna do it again
muffin man's downstairs
probably your boy lemon we gonna do that
again I'm coming your way yeah yeah
we got him out of pocket now yeah
Waltz is that his name whoa come here
no no no no no
all right go down and come off the side
go down and come out the side
jump on
that no he don't he don't jump on
oh damn come up here wait let's go let's
go let's go pop on
we don't play Halo we
there you go my bad my bad guys return
our flag
flag
I don't know where I am
oh yeah you missed Alexa
cause that rock blocked us
let me shoot oh
look
the carrier has revealed themselves
jump down
yo the bike is over here come on fellas
it didn't know where to go return it
return it has been returned
oh God damn it goddamn ship knock me
down
oh my God slobo came out of nowhere
again
put that down put that down oh man I ran
out of ammo and I had to jump on slow-mo
too
oh
my game crashed they was like jumping oh
no the game crash on the other team it's
okay we're fine
oh man the DDOS attack
[Laughter]
I will say Cog works in the tech
industry but I don't mean nothing
but we had that we had that flag though
how many people you guys got now
is it even only on Xbox can anybody pull
up yes ksrt I jump on and the first
thing I hear is 108 dragons
dude in the Valley of Death my favorite
game it's my favorite game that's what's
up yo are you guys are you guys doing uh
do you guys got even or is it oh [ __ ] I
don't know you'll be back
someone told me how what we're looking
like on the uh
our um let's see yeah wait one two three
no no no no
8v7 right now
oh you talk about all the balance
yeah
you need another body yeah yeah we could
use another one
right I'll jump just left
7v7 now
oh yeah we don't need no one now
yeah sit down and chill out bro
you see him playing in my game right
I just joined so like I want to play
forget that game
trying to find a
actually
we gotta do it for the hell of it hold
on
buyer's house
oh okay
and we make sure
you might want to push the the score to
win up to 100.
hold up
uh violin can go ahead and join
oh okay
God
I don't think report reports spam or
Android phones work
that's fine
it keeps saying you one you won this
from Walmart I don't shop anymore my
brother
and like and I keep reporting spam and
it just keeps getting back no it's mad
spam going on lately yeah
one of my Outlook email addresses is
nothing but that
all right are you doing stuff on here
that I keep reporting and blocking them
are you in here
oh my God you went
I don't no I don't see I think so
the screen calibration oh that's good
no you guys can join the party just join
the party it's not locked before I do
this damn podcast today last of the Year
baby
I've never done this this is this is an
infection I've never done this infection
yeah with this
you didn't put it on that crazy level
right no this is all Behemoth on
Behemoth no it's not yes no it's a
custom map oh it's showing okay like I
guess they still didn't fix that bug
where like if someone changes things it
doesn't show the game yeah show for the
rest of the day oh okay
they got Series wise that's why yo you
stupid
I look crazy
don't worry about it ain't gonna take no
long trips let's go that's crazy
all right so what we doing it's
infection
s
wait a minute oh someone's already here
infection
what's the what's the point no we have
to we have to stay alive for four
minutes
yeah yeah we have to stay alive for four
minutes
every time you die you come back as an
infected
oh Lord have mercy
get all on top of the house
I'm getting off the house
to be on the grave
oh yeah everybody trying to run in the
bushes yeah
attic like I'm gonna be on the outskirts
and nobody
outside upside your head
play with me if you like
this man
crazy
don't touch me with your affection wait
a minute how do you win that's right
he's the last one yeah
yes it was it was cocked yeah
so how did they turn though and when you
get killed when you kill someone oh
so the best thing you can do
yeah
Got The High Ground man all right there
he is there he's over there
okay that dude right there he need a
booster shot that dude right there
left your body
oh yo dudes up top looking for something
we need to kill something
don't bring that nonsense with you
yeah
[Music]
oh there's mad weapons back here yeah
you go go check that out you go let me
know how that works
oh no
yo my man
[Music]
why has it turned one person into a
zombie
go over there
you showed us it was safe there you are
hey thank you for your service thank you
for your service
it was real gangster to go out there
first look the weapon is completely
emptied
oh there's two there's two zombies
I don't know
there's just two he got someone he's got
he got someone
out here
I literally have not seen the single
obviously
that's because Tina red lightning hit
the ground that was yeah that's crazy
yo dirt the lighting they've done in
this is ridiculous
yeah the lighting they've done in this
game is ridiculous yes insane
let me see the world so I can go in here
fine
are you a ninja murder now you know what
I'm I'm going over there with y'all yeah
it may not be Chicago
I made a community we made a community
over here oh kids lives in here
oh the weapons respawned too
oh they're right there
[ __ ]
um
half the team is a zombie oh
y'all some terrible demons
[Laughter]
[Music]
that is ridiculous
[Applause]
there was no way lemon saw me legitly so
what I was a sucker on the hilltop so
what right that's the whole point though
that's what you have to do you have to
do that I have people behind me and I'm
talking crazy
oh
don't let him get to us yeah if you let
him kill you so help me God
there's one in him there's 30. but we
gotta be some we got to be some
dysfunctional people for 30 people on a
road to be killed by one person
what the [ __ ]
don't
let him get us that's how we lose
trees
look look I got the boom stick with 20
shots
come on man run to the light
oh come on
man it's not safe out there by yourself
wow
Bob said I'm back baby oh
hey look out for each other man
you know what's worse than look out for
each other man you know what's worse
foreign
look out for each other
yo listen push up on that d-pad give
people Direction man so we know where
they coming from oh we stitching
stitching challenge
he might be playing for the other side
I put two marks where I saw they're
trying to use these trees to get close
to us right there you know we out here
super Telly they out there
hiding right there
you go
look at drunken he's like I'm bored I'm
doing charity work right now
they terrorizing p-yd
yeah they run inside the sound like
crackheads
it's hair Rock and chicken I mean attic
I do one shot on man
yeah it's three
if they were smart they would be jumping
drunken ninja he's the only one away
from us yeah
[Applause]
I'm tired
smoothly
oh they they made me the uh
yeah
oh
[Music]
come here
oh sorry I had to beat you brother happy
birthday
[Laughter]
oh
you're at again terrorized out here
sabotage and basis oh yeah yeah I got
the hang of this now follow lemon I got
you I'll take you to the promised land
it's all good
Lemonis I'm back
like I'm with I'm with cuck
I'm gonna do some snitching
behind me bro
that's mad cheap
easily coerced
Ure
you know
you gotta catch somebody slipping
how to come here behind you
the Predator he's a predator
oh got him I don't think this game is
supposed to be us hunting
go back
we need to start with two zombies and
make him more interesting though yeah
because this is a little while for what
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my God
there's another one
like I'm not moving
to the strategy man look man
[Music]
myself
oh don't do that
sorry back oh they coming in droves all
right hey hey all zombies all zombies
we're going in at the same time
all right all right under every all the
zombies get on the on the house all the
zombies get on the house
oh everyone to me on me somewhere else
yeah go go go go go go go
[Applause]
yeah
are we gonna zerk this out
oh
fight him find him there's someone alive
find him
[Music]
[Laughter]
I was ready
for all the smoke you ain't lying
damn that was fire I was ready no
welcome you're in the upside down now
you know like when you die when you when
you die as a zombie you're on the upside
down world you have to leave it
yeah I don't know
stranger thing map is dope Camp Crystal
all right I got maybe one or two more
games and then we're probably gonna jump
on demia
all right
so I'm sending the other people
here
all right let's try to find something
else here Corgi that infection was fun
I'm not gonna lie
it was they do got a balance they do got
to balance it though for the zombies
though yeah yeah at least start them for
like yeah yeah
[Music]
all you need is two zombies an addict
just take off the one shot and it'll be
perfect
make it like two shots
Oreo you hungry yeah we need like one
like two or three hits to kill them
all right who needs an invite
I think everybody's here are we doing
infection again no yeah we're doing that
again all right kind of advocate uh
sliders
balance it yourself it's Dodge it's
Forge
unlimited score to win
I think that's the most kills I've had
in this in this game
I I was killing people left and right
man
actually I want to play this one I
actually really did want to play this I
hope where is it go for it
whatever let's go go baby it's your
birthday it's gonna be like a one-on
all of us kind of thing I want an uptime
James yeah
I can't I can't wait for dimio though
that's a real 1970s
that was cool when you were 10 years old
I don't think it was cool man
used to be killing you they used to pick
one arm and everybody
oh absolutely two days in New York the
first day in Halloween dude's got socks
with flowers with rocks in them Let's Go
Crazy
or soap
soap is dangerous when they swung at 100
miles an hour did you say eight sticks
of butter in a sauce what yeah
for sure frozen steak
pepper in that they make it more
potentials out
Halloween it was Halloween New Year's
and
Fourth of July was the three three days
you had to you you had to watch your ass
I knew yes it's the day in New York
everybody assumes that you could ride
the trains and buses for free yeah my
God remember that yeah
that was a fake rumor oh that's okay
Transit is freeze everybody anyways
oh man memories
facts
I miss living New York but I don't
listen living in New York
oh what is this what is this what is
this
there's someone up there throwing the
ball
what yo
yo okay
yeah
I don't have a repulsa
you have a one-use repulsa
one of them one of them joints is out of
pocket one of these Boulders is doing
their own thing I don't know
oh man oh boy I thought it was so close
to him
go go you can win you you just have to
get to him directed the balls yes
oh you kicking stuff to hit us you can't
get him let's get him oh we just gotta
get to the Finish Line no okay okay
meatballs
no it's it's a uh it's inspired by Mario
party uh mini game oh okay yo oh I'm so
screwed I'm so scared I'm so scared
okay
you do get one used you get one news
oh
[Music]
pop me
the physics
[Applause]
[Music]
got me got me good man
is this switching the person up there
or is it the same person
no no there's someone up there doing
this oh these phones
right it got home and bolded this is
crazy
I'm sorry I just repelled that no
pancake to the other person
[Music]
thank you
yes all right
oh watch that one that's that one that
come with the tracking nice and slow
yo he holding on to that wall for
deadline yeah that's my strategy man I
was almost there in the boulder knocked
me literally all the way down the hill I
was like oh man
folders
oh I'm so screwed I'm so screwed I'm so
screwed
whoa kill him that's it for me
I don't think HALO jump is gonna work
[Music]
oh wow wow
[Music]
that holder knocked the brakes off
[Music]
no no
oh how the hell
11 is survive in this oh oh there you go
oh God damn it I was gonna make it
that was a pretty footwork yeah
yeah no see everybody's trying to copy
people
all right
look how many people we've had in here
dude this is crazy Rockies
are fighting each other exactly
oh
right not in slow motion
I still got my Repulsor get out of here
we making it
come on oh you're supposed to save me
that was me I got you money yeah
[Laughter]
I got first
all right what decides if it's a tie or
a win yeah
I think I think we do I think we do one
for each person everybody on a nice
shiny Olive
to myself
certain time
and once again asking for someone with a
republican damn
yeah
I just got shot all the way back down
past the starting line that's what
happened oh you guys are so lucky his
boaters glitched he couldn't use his
motor
yo yo yo yo
yeah my bad my bad I lucked out there
I think it does one for each person
I gotta go man I gotta make good playing
with y'all always a pleasure you already
know all right brother all right
all right man all right
no after this round I'm gonna
all right I already gotcha
I got one for you guys I think you guys
gonna like come with me if you want to
live all right
depending on somebody
that's chilling next to each other and
hope someone else sees that repulsory
instead of them
ow
I see I'm not the only one who got out
I'm free I got out man let's get it
another one whoa oh man
let's go wait cool Buck hit got hit
guard
who's still who's still climbing who's
still climbing either he's in debt look
at his minus 100. oh money
my bank account
move out
oh yeah probably started over
oh
what happened glitchy bro I think you're
changing the folders
yeah I I got one for you guys
it was my turn oh I'm sorry
all right so Mario I survived four
rounds not bad
I died four times but I you know no
assists I didn't know you can insist
and I got one kill how I get a Kill
like a seven around survived let's go
let's go awesome
Boulder ball
Nova
they need to compile all the Wild Force
maps and modes like this into a four guy
style playlist
dude they got a whole bunch of modes I
could do before like a spider monkey
speed Halo Hopper suit
like a cart
they got that they got that they got uh
I want to do one of those
maybe not right now but definitely would
like to try that
no back
all right man let's break it up in here
yeah it's crazy so I think what I have
to do is just click any of them then
yeah
we put these modes or these game modes
in like the normal playlist or are they
only left on Forge
I think it's forage specific
oh okay
all right
so these are these um
Community made uh games or is it made by
their community
well these these people need to look at
some of these games be like yeah we need
to steal some of these ideas
for the last 10 years for real they had
that at launch
all right all right so this is very much
because I'm having fun so I have
15 codes and anyone that finishes all
three of these I will give you one of
the codes
oh
so we'll be doing a little giveaway if
you're finished coach for what the first
one to finish all three will get a coat
later
code to what you're in a giveaway
I want to get one free
you have to start number one
what is this
what are we doing it's it's American
Ninja Warriors
don't shoot at people don't shoot
all right yeah I didn't I didn't realize
American Ninja Warrior I'm dead oh you
gotta use the grappling no
don't use the grappling hook either
unless you unless you absolutely have to
I couldn't find the rules to this place
who's making all his rules no that
everything every playlist has a rule
that you have to use it for but I
couldn't find the uh the the rules for
this one
oh
where exactly shoot this grapple Hood
too what the hell monkey bars
this is wow
I have no idea what's going on me
neither
this is crazy
someone keeps going to three you gotta
go one two and three you can't just do
three
all right that didn't work too okay
still stuck on the first part if
someone's using a grappling hook don't
think I don't see that
no
no
oh [ __ ]
I made it
so before I hit the jump on it
oh man yo Kyle Wallace
I ain't the only one using grappling
hooks out here that's what I'm saying
yeah
I'm just saying
I'll keep hearing it
dang it
oh no God damn it no wait
I just realized the numbers show a
different area yeah
I didn't know that at all we have to
complete one two and then three
ah I don't know how the [ __ ] we're gonna
do this man we need something
oh
they're streaming
[Music]
to watch damn
oh what
oh man
dang it where am I supposed to go
and number two
there we go
oh
yeah
what was we doing it's more now man
it happened to me
I didn't even get to the next part I
don't even understand
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm just playing
what did you set it off
this is the problem
we devolved into chaos
oh no
yeah
so why can't you use the grappling hooks
[Laughter]
okay okay
[Laughter]
all right all right all right hey hey
you can use the grappling hook for the
first part now
all right oh man no I'm saying like this
jumping part after you grabs
[Music]
it's not me I am done I'm just uh they
used to date to call me back back in the
day man oh crap
okay
a pip name back slap said with me now
what is
what's your name right here what what
did you mean
the countless
oh my God
hey hey someone gets to the second part
with me real quick right before
man I don't even know what this I don't
even know what to do in the second part
gotta time your jumps but I don't even
know like watch this hold up hold up
hold up someone come right behind me do
it and then I'm gonna grapple you and
see if he'll sling me over the map
oh you you baby
no I can never make that
ain't for that this is the puck
everybody mess up it
just look when you grapple it looks up
and you go
oh
that part
I gotta remember the whole place
you pushed me off you son of a [ __ ]
oh no it's like a management crew
my bad oh hey who did that
I didn't mean to Grapple whoever that
was
that was an accident
[Music]
no sorry
this is impossible yeah what I don't
understand
sometimes the graphics
and sometimes it doesn't sometimes to
mantle sometimes to go
oh man enjoys
the second one is
you guys know there's like portals on
the left and right to show you uh yeah
like people doing it people doing it I'm
spectating I don't know why it takes my
grapple hook when I get to this [ __ ]
section though like come on man what the
[ __ ]
language
who's this over there shooting at it
hello
sorry
seriously
word oh my God
is that the blades again is
this what these happened again
what the [ __ ] who made this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] bro be monetized oh we're
gonna demonetized for a language
we've been demonetized for a minute
of this man
oh I didn't mean to kill you
yeah okay thanks somebody did it yeah
I need to try three yet two was terrible
yeah two two is ridiculous I have no
idea
we've been at this for almost 11 minutes
yeah I finally made it but I'm done with
this [ __ ]
foreign
go
[ __ ] you
that's so cute
yeah those wrong like half an inch wide
I think I think everyone's done
yeah
for real oh without now we're getting
through punching each other again
that's what's going on man that's what's
happening I see it in the streets you
are me I'm taking me
okay
oh because I'm out enjoy the recipe
you know what we after this we're gonna
try that map again with more people the
one that we did at the beginning the sky
wars but after that I'm done
yeah
I got one more on me
yeah I got one Skyward it's crazy
what are we doing now
how one two three swords
at Castle Wars we need one more person
guys
if they catch a flag again or is it just
yeah
yeah
we just lost
so okay we need people from the other
team to switch over here
with this hold up me I don't know how
many you got all each ones I think we're
just down by one
no we're we should be even now I think
we're eating yeah
let go
I see I hear you uh Lord Metro
man yo chicken I'm sucking uh
[ __ ] daily last night
man
yeah Devin had another drunk episode
he did
um
what a dealer say he probably just like
uh you're you're welcome it was just
like you he would just uh just taking it
all in
looks like he was just listening to it
all hey he's having a midlife
you okay with it it's all right
I mean he's bursting it's not bad he
could be turning 40. like damn it's old
I'm 40 pyd so screws
respect back to the old cheese
to school exactly 26.
oh yeah I'll be forgetting I've been
forgetting to add against PG it's not
TTS I'll be 30 in April
all right
I'm 48. you know I'm just I'm just
saying though
remember Chris Rock told Kevin Hart he
was 50. damn that's how I'm feeling
right now
but they won't make our lives
oh my God this is ridiculous
okay I like this I like this this one is
hilarious
yeah there's bots in US
uh chivalry too I've been playing sugar
yeah chivalry
[Music]
oh my God man they're just everywhere
they're like 30 deep on that bridge
he was quiet that first one though
I'm on the way back
we got in there
yeah
I want your back got your back watch
your back let your back
I'm spawned already yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
what about now Jackie
yeah
let's go
oh they did that bad dude
I took his his over shirt off
I need some grapple hook uh shots on
here
everywhere
oh yeah
oh my God
not in here
if you use the Razorbacks don't use it
man no yeah yeah okay all right
dudes don't come outside unless they got
their best
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
no you don't follow me
it's in the middle the over Show's in
the middle
don't worry about it don't you worry
about where it's at yeah
that's cause people got killed
my vehicles but they get grenades
they're on the top they're on the second
floor
oh jump him that's the one yeah you back
it up now yeah yeah what's up what's up
what's good what's good
what's really good
it was five of y'all yeah
[Laughter]
yo you guys just people we jumped him
in that block don't worry about it okay
okay
[Music]
nobody's Wilding down the street
let's go let's go
yeah oh my God man look the lunge is
crazy
are you backing up
[Laughter]
the Samurai Showdown The Showdown wow
y'all not even trying to take our flag I
ain't about that it's just beef it's
just beef
is that to do with the objective
come on come inside
[Music]
yo what's good what's good
[Music]
how you are
I know
right here
it wasn't in your car
right here I love you
listen
hmm everything
[Music]
to y'all
jump on the back jump in the back
come back
oh man
I appreciate the happy birthday wishes
[Music]
you don't think that's balanced I
think
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's go
oh
distraction that was a distraction
took me the whole match I don't even
know who I hit and it threw them in the
back
that's it
perfect
oh that's the muffin man I'm sorry
it had to be you buffing bottom sorry
oh
y'all
all right
it's not like I complaining
right that's what we doing we mad
but they're with me
did I just shake them out of here
that I got that was nice
I guess okay
get over here
let's show that boy get down
[Laughter]
oh no he can't let him talk to you like
that
[Music]
um I'm on the way again let's grab the
flag I'll come protect y'all I'm on the
way
available
oh my God
those strategy evolved right there
This Is War all the way
look at all the solids
oh man
that's what she said wow
that's right cut up with the cutter
man
his entrance
get out of here
all right push this push the bridge push
the bridge
do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
come on
times infinity
oh
yeah
[Applause]
okay okay
where'd he go
ES
I gotta here
what's up what's up what's up what's up
what's up what's up what's up what's up
what's up
let's go man
come out and play come on
yeah oh they did yeah
[Music]
look
you got you got slow mo actually trying
to do something with you guys just not
paying attention
[Music]
everyone hey no no here on the left on
the left everyone on the left Drive push
push let's go Volcan get on one
to metal overshield available
[Music]
yeah yeah there you go there you go
because I'll have overshills on like
three of y'all all right everyone
getting a vehicle let's go let's go
let's go rob him now
let's get them now you
know we ride out Rough Riders
[Music]
my friend
like six opportunity
[Music]
[Applause]
that's crazy
now you got to get your chain back
just hold off for three minutes
that's right
your heart geek you are so dirty right
now I love it
I love it I said put trucks all in the
front
going in here boy
[Laughter]
light them up y'all know what they do
they're Bots are better than our Bots
we gonna put that in there
oh
my babe I got my battle security
[Music]
system
security that's right
we got the shooters if you try to come
through what
we're gonna do it
yeah
there you go
dogs all cocky man
they're coming in with the Razorback
they're coming in with the Razorback
clutter it up
to you brother
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't worry about how he's doing it
yeah I like that you know what to do
yeah
[Music]
I'm very upset
I'll be my feelings there but let me
hear this in this bag
let's go
let's go
straight
out yourself
Hey look
let's go
this is the Lord's House
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
a triple kill an Overkill a kill tacular
a kilotrosity a killing a madrana
I got four overkills though
did you get seven kills seven triple
kills I got two one
six double kills one niece killing three
I got 11 ball true one Warrior he
doesn't react to like double or triple
Cuts I mean anything you got a sword
[Music]
good [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no don't let them have they change we
won not only do we have to change we
have their name too we won
[Laughter]
see that's what I'm saying man like like
they gotta find a good way of getting
this community stuff to like the masses
because that was fun like that
and you know what's crazy we played for
three and a half hours and didn't do
anything twice really like actually did
you do the um the one with the multiple
Dimensions no I couldn't yeah
it's really cool so what was that one we
did where it was like um the space one
was a lot of vehicles a lot of Air
Combat vehicles and stuff oh that was uh
uh facing Laurel it's that's what that
was called that was a remake of like a
doom map or something like that
uh okay okay that was interesting yeah
Doom are quite one or the other oh Doom
I think you make Dune like Dua no uh
Quake It was one of those two
okay okay
when do you guys want to do the demio
thing probably like I just got I guess
six o'clock yeah like six I just gotta
get a little food
it's fine yeah six is good all right
boys
[Music]
happy birthday I said are y'all doing
demio on VR
whatever you want to play oh wow cool
yeah oh someone made the The maduro's
Mask clock tower map stop
that's crazy just drop me a message yeah
drop us a message do you want to play
because that'll be four that'll be me
you and him and I
I don't know I don't know if I have the
meal I may have bought it on for on
Oculus it works
it works yeah
just you could you could download it on
um um on the on PC just download the
Oculus version on PC and then when you
when you was about to launch the app
launch it in desktop mode and that's how
you play it without VR PC so you don't
have to buy it twice if you already have
it on um
on VR cool all right let me do that I
gotta check in with the family maker
oh you got to do that we'll go we're
gonna go back live at six guys and we'll
go play demia because I want it to be
two separate streams because the the
developers to make that they made a
great game they deserve that that
content